l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur Frédéric
petit pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre des armées les
Ukrainiens souffrent zchant y vachant
comme on dit dans la région pour leur
liberté et pour la nôtre je le disais
ici le 24 février 22 au matin la guerre
d'Ukraine c'est la confrontation de deux
modèles
entre Atlantique et Méditerranée entre
Baltique et M noire sur ces terres
européennes qui nous ont vu nous
déchirer pendant des siècles de guerr de
migration déjà en tout sens de chocs
culturel et religieux lequel de ces deux
modèles est en mesure de faire l'unité
l'impérialisme l'autocratie simpliste la
loi du plus fort non pour nous
démocrates européens c'est uni dans la
diversité et même uni dans nos
différences et nos divergences que nous
pourrons affronter le 21e
siècle pour nous démocrates européens
les relations économiques ce sont les
fonds de convergence et de solidarité
pas le chantage au gaz pour nous la
diversité des langues est aussi
indispensable à l'humanisme et à la
démocratie que la biodiversité à la
planète pour nous la mobilité c'est
erasmous pas le nettoyage ethnique en
Crimée et dans le donbas pour nous
démocrates européens la démocratie exige
qu'on la défende lorsqu'elle est
agressée bien et l'Ukraine fait partie
de la famille des démocraties
européennes absolument aujourd'hui la
situation militaire semble stable et la
fatigue supposée des Ukrainiens n'est
que l'une des multiples narrations de la
guerre de désinformation russe qui fait
rage y compris en France cette longue
bataille défensive nous pouvons et nous
devrons l'emporter avec ou sans les
États-Unis car elle est d'abord et avant
tout la nôtre et nous sommes et nous
serons de plus en plus seuls en face de
notre destin et celui des enfants de nos
petits-enfants pour citer vois vavel sur
l'Union européenne c'est bien la patrie
de nos patries qui est en danger
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où nos
livraisons marquent le pas comment notre
pays se prépare-t-il à affronter ce défi
militaire et industriel de la défense de
nos démocraties qu'elle échéance à 3
semaines à 3 mois à 3 ans je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Patricia mirales ministre en
charge des anciens combattants merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
tout d'abord je vous prie d'excuser le
ministre des armées qui est actuellement
en déplacement comme vous le savez
depuis le début de la guerre la France
s'est engagée à soutenir l'Ukraine dans
sa légitime défense contre l'agression
de la Russie ce soutien militaire répond
toujours au mêmes critères clairement
définis par le Président de la
République une aide utile une aide qui
ne conduise pas à l'escalade et une aide
qui n'affaiblisse pas la défense de la
France une des spécificités de notre
soutien militaire est que nous
fournissons des capacités complètes
équipement formation maintenance comme
pour les les canons César qui a qui a
qui a fait leur preuve je rappelle le
rapport des députés Lionel royéperro et
Christophe nagelen ce soutien doit
s'inscrire dans la durée vous avez
raison de souligner que nous ne pouvons
indéfiniment puiser dans les stocks de
nos forces armées c'est ce qu'a initié
le ministre des armées à Kiev en
septembre dernier nous passons d'une
logique de cession à une logique de
partenariat industriel entre l'Ukraine
et les entreprises françaises
parallèlement vous avez voté en loi de
finances de fin de gestion le
réamendement du euh euh du fond spécial
pour l'Ukraine qui permet de lui fournir
les armements à hauteur de 200 millions
nous nous coordonnons avec nos
partenaires européens et nos alliés de
l'OTAN pour structurer l'aide à
l'Ukraine dans ce cadre la France
apporte une contribution majeure en
prenant la tête d'une coalition
capacitaire dans le domaine de
l'artillerie enfin la France continue
d'apporter un soutien déterminant à
l'Ukraine par les formations ce sont
près de 8000 militaires Ukrainiens en
2023 que nous avons formé environ 1/4
des soldats euh formé aussi dans le
cadre de l'opération EAN ces formations
ont vocation à à se poursuivre en 2024
et à s'étendre à d'autres domaines
monsieur le député je vous remercie je
vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre moral
luuissier pour le groupe
lotte merci madame la Présidente la
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des solidarités et des Familles de
France Madame le Ministre comme vous le
savez la proposition de loi bien
vieillir a été adoptée en première
lecture en séance publique le 23
novembre der dernier à l'Assemblée
nationale malgré une intention très
ambitieuse le texte ne s'accompagne pas
des financements en effet au-delà de
quelques dispositions visant à garantir
les droits des personnes âgées et à
lutter contre la maltraitance en épad ce
texte n'est pas une réponse à mon sens
suffisante aux en aux enjeux du
vieillissement et de la perte
d'autonomie d'une partie de la
population le 17 novembre dernier vous
avez vous-même admis dans le cadre de la
présentation d'une feuille de route
interministérielle le principe d'une loi
de programmation grand âge qui qui
devrait être présenté d'ici l'été 2024
celle-ci devrait comporter une prise en
charge par l'État dès 2025 de la moitié
des nouvelles politiques d'autonomie une
tarification forfaitaire pour les aides
à domicile un protocole pluréannuel pour
le recrutement des 50000 postes en EPAD
pour 2030 et une cartographie des
besoins des 7 des 7500 EPAD Madame le
Ministre pourriz-vous nous assurer des
financements nécessaires reflétant les
besoins des personnes en situation
d'autonomie et de dépendance résidant en
structure sociale médicos-social ou
nécessitant des soins à domicile par
ailleurs la reconnaissance des
accompagnants et des salariés d'pades
sera-t-elle incluse dans le cadre du
futur
texte je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Aurore berger ministre des
Solidarités des familles merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Pierre Morel
aluissier merci de saluer aussi le vote
qui a été très large dans le cadre de la
proposition à bien vieillir et votre
groupe y a pris toute sa part et je vous
en remercie une nouvelle fois
oui nous avons présenté une stratégie
interministérielle de nombreux membres
du gouvernement étaient présents parce
que c'est bien toute notre société qui
doit s'adapter à l'un des défis majeurs
et heureux de notre société qui est
quand même que nous avons une espérance
de vie en bonne santé qui progresse
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais pour
beaucoup de Français c'est aussi devenu
une source d'angoisse d'inquiétude de
charge sur comment ils vont faire face
eux-mêmes à ce vieillissement et comment
évidemment ils feront face au
vieillissement de leurs parents et de
leurs grands-parents pour y répondre
nous avons besoin d'une loi de Programm
tion c'est l'engagement que j'ai pris
c'est surtout l'engagement que la
première ministre a pris en fixant un
calendrier à savoir que je dois
présenter cette loi à l'été prochain de
manière à ce qu'elle puisse être
définitivement adoptée à la fin de
l'année 2024 cette loi elle doit
répondre à plusieurs grandes questions
face aux nouveaux besoins dans notre
société quels sont évidemment les
leviers d'offre que nous devons
construire pour sortir de cette logique
à la fois du tout domicile du tout épad
nous devons construire des offres
nouvelles quels sont les leviers de
financement nouveaux que nous devons
réussir à déterminer à déterminer
ensemble dans le cadre de cette
trajectoire comment avoir les
compétences nécessaires notamment en
terme de professionnel qualifiés c'est
donc cela les questions à auxquelles ce
projet de loi doit pouvoir répondre loi
de programmation les besoins nouveaux
les offres nouvelles les besoins de
financement nouveaux la trajectoire que
nous nous fixons c'est un défi essentiel
que notre pays doit relever en 2030 un
français sur TR aura plus de 60 ans ça
doit être une chance pour notre pays une
opportunité et déjà janvier prochain
j'aurai l'occasion de lancer cette
coconstruction avec les parlementaires
puisque je solliciterai l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires représentés à
l'Assemblée au Sénat pour qu'on a une
vraie construction cette loi je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur le député oui madame
la ministre j'entends bien l'orientation
je vous le redit aujourd'hui il y a une
souffrance dans les épades il y a une
vraie difficulté au niveau des des aides
soignants il faut vraiment que ça aille
très vite parce que depuis le temps
qu'on dit qu'il y aura une loi grand âge
il est temps de mettre maintenant les
choses en place merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Frédérique
meunier pour le coupl
républicain merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre de nombreux
établissements de santé subisse de plein
fouet la réalité de la politique
gouvernementale de transfert du paiement
de vos choix politiques vers nos
établissements médicaux sociaux et
hospitaliers en effet rien que dans mon
département la coraise motion sur la
situation budgétaire des épades et des
centres hospitaliers sont votés
demandant à l'état de prendre ses
responsabilité ces établissements font
face à des situations budgétaires
inédites après la forte inflation de
2021 notamment pour les dépenses
alimentaires et énergétiques après les
difficultés de recrutement avec une
pénurie de médecins infirmiers et aide
soignant nécessitant un recours coûteux
à l'intérim votre politique est insensé
quand l'État décide des mesures
salariales certes nécessaires quand
l'État décide des mesures de soutien au
pouvoir d'achat des agents de la
fonction publique quand l'État décide
les revalorisations salariales du
travail de nuit des gardes du du
dimanche des jours fériers mais quand
l'État oublie de compenser
financièrement cette augmentation de
charges sociales nouvelles qui l'a
imposé les laissant à la charge seulle
de ces établissements médicaux c'est
irraisonnable en conséquence ces
dispositions gouvernementales menacent
la santé financière de nos
établissements certains étant même dans
l'obligation d'ouvrir une ligne de
trésorerie pour éviter le défaut de
paiement madame la ministre allez-vous
prendre en compte l'urgence de la
situation financière inquiétante et
dégager des crédits pour les les
établissements en grande
difficulté je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame aard berger ministre des
Solidarités et des famille merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Frédérique
Meier est-ce qu'il y a urgence la
réponse est évidemment oui et vous avez
raison de le dire de cette manière
comment est-ce que nous agissons d'abord
je crois qu'il était temps de ne plus
avoir de barrière entre sanitaire et
médico-social parce que ça a généré je
le crois beaucoup de frustration et de
tension inutile entre deux secteurs qui
doivent travailler ensemble c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai annoncé en
effet que quand il y a des
revalorisations nuit et weekend dans le
secteur sanitaire ça doit être la même
chose dans le médicosocial évidemment
quand sont les établissements publics
c'est l'État qui prend sa charge mais il
y a aussi évidemment ce qui est à la
charge des départements notamment sur la
question des éepad et des établissements
médicaux-sociaux concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dès 2024 à la demande de la
première ministre nous allons augmenter
le soutien au département au conseils
départementaux de 150 millions d'euros
concrètement ça veut dire que plus aucun
département dans notre pays sera
compensé à moins de 40 % de ses dépenses
en matière d'appat c'est une mesure
essentielle on va aller plus loin
puisque je réunis dès janvier prochain
le comité des financeurs c'est-à-dire
les conseils départementaux la CNSA avec
une feuille de route que je leur est
proposé et qui va être discuté qui est
que désormais à partir de 2025 50 % de
toutes les dépenses nouvelles des
départements en matière d'autonomie soit
compensé par l'État ce qui serait
absolument inédit comme soutien de la
part de de l'État au département enfin
il y a évidemment des situations
d'urgence situations d'urgence dans un
certain nombre d'établissements vous
l'avez dit concrètement en 2023 ça s'est
traduit par près de 700 millions d'euros
que nous avons débloqué pour aider et
accompagner plus de 7000 établissements
médicaux sociaux ou service d'aide à
domicile pour la corz c'est par exemple
plus de 5 millions d'euros qui ont été
débloqués ça répond à l'urgence et nous
allons avancer et sur le soutien au
département et avec une loi de
programmation pour avoir une vraie
trajectoire
pluri-annuelle je vous remercie madame
la ministre madame la députée oui madame
la ministre j'ai bien entendu ce que
vous avez dit c'est vrai que il faut
compenser les charges qui ne cessent
d'augmenter et il n'y a pas d'amour sans
preuve d'amour donc je sais que vous
nous
aimez je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Marie agès poussier vinsbag pour
le groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique monsieur le ministre durant
plus d'une vingtaine d'années les
différents gouvernements de gauche et de
droite il faut bien le reconnaître se
sont trompés oui ils se sont trompés en
M imaginant que la dématérialisation
permettrait de remplacer les hommes et
les femmes qui accueillaient nos
concitoyens dans un grand nombre de
services publics fort de ce constat et
du sentiment d'abandon vécu par un grand
nombre de nos concitoyens et notamment
en milieu rural le gouvernement à la
demande du Président de la République a
mis en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement sur l'ensemble ble du
territoire au travers des maisons France
service ainsi contrairement à ce que
disent certains dans le vrai monde la
situation s'améliore et de nombreux
Français peuvent avoir accès à des
services dont ils n'ont jamais pu avoir
accès auparavant que ce soit au travers
des maisons France service ou au travers
des bus France service ce sont des
territoires très éloignés parfois isolés
qui dispose aujourd'hui de permanence et
d'un accès au servic public monsieur le
ministre je sais que que ce sujet vous
tient particulièrement à cœur c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez indiquer à la représentation
nationale que vous et vos équipeuez
inlassablement à travailler sur ce sujet
et que vous considérez que notre
objectif est toujours celui de faire
mieux monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous
nous préciser quelles sont vos nouvelles
priorités pour continuer ce travail de
réconciliation entre nos concitoyens et
nos services publics quels sont vos
objectifs quels sont les objectifs que
vous vous fixez notamment pour étendre
et mieux faire connaître ce dispositif
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Stanislas Guerini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction
publique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la député poussier vinsbach merci de
m'interroger sur un dispositif qui fait
pas tout le temps la une de la presse
nationale qui fait pas tout le temps les
chaînes d'info les bandeaux des chaînes
d'info en continu mais qui change la vie
des gens qui s'appelle France service je
veux saluer votre investissement
remarquable sur France service le
travail que vous avez mené avec le
sénateur delcro les propositions que
vous avez formulé et vous savez beaucoup
ont été reprises j'étais il y a quelques
jours à l'anon pour inaugurer un espace
France service et c'était important pour
moi à deux titres d'abord parce que
c'était dans une sous-préfecture et que
suite au choix du président de la
République nous investissons dans les
réseaux de sous-préfecture et nous
réouvrons des sous-préfectures mais
c'est très important de remettre des
services publics dans nos
sous-préfectures à l'anon j'ai croisé
certains de nos concitoyens qui
retrouvait le chemin d'une
sous-préfecture c'est-à-dire le chemin
de l'État sur le territoire et puis
c'était important parce que c'était la
2700e maison France service que nous
avons réouverte c'est-à-dire que nous
avons relevé la promesse du président de
la République c'était au lendemain du
grand débat national ramener des
services publics à moins de 30 minutes
physique
de chacun de nos concitoyens c'est
désormais chose faite madame la députée
puisque c'est à moins de 20 minutes de
chaque Français que se trouve une espace
France service mais France service ça
marche aussi parce que plus de 8 fois
sur 10 quand quelqu'un vient dans une
maison France service son sujet est
traité au moment où il en sort France
service ça marche parce qu'il y a des
agents qui sont bien formés je veux en
vous répondant les saluer aujourd'hui
nous allons continuer à investir sur
leur niveau de compétence et France
service ça marche parce parce que tout
le monde tire dans la même direction
l'État les élus locaux tous les acteurs
des territoires font ensemble et nous
allons continuer à faire de même en
investissant en relevant le ticket de
financement de 30000 à 50000 € pour
chacun des espaces France service en
mettant des moyens humains
supplémentaire vous le voyez madame la
députée on lâche rien et on accélère
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame la députée merci Monsieur le
Ministre ce que j'espère c'est que nous
pourrons aussi envisager
l'expérimentation pourquoi pas avec des
collectivités qui le souhaiteraient
notamment les communes rurales pour le
dernier kilomètre j'y tiens beaucoup et
j'espère que nous pourrons examiner
cette possibilité dans les mois venir
merci merci beaucoup mes chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur José gonzalz
pour le rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national merci madame la présidente
madame messieurs les ministres
honorables collègues une fois de plus
votre gouvernement apprête à trahir les
classes moyennes françaises ces
travailleurs et retraités qui font tenir
notre pays debout voilà 10 longues
années qu'Emmanuel Macron accable et les
familles françaises de taxes et impôts
diverses alors que nos compatriotes
plébiscitai les mesures sur le pouvoir
d'achat proposé par Marine Le Pen vous
avez cherché à faire diversion avec des
promesses que vous saviez
intenables ainsi au printemps dernier
Gabriel Atal et Emmanuel Macron ont
promis aux classes moyennees 2 milliards
d'euros de pèse d'impôt les députés du
rassemblement national avaient dénoncé
ce mensonge grossier et hélas nous
avions raison alors que les médias
étaient focalisés sur l'immigration et
que les familles françaises veulent
couper avec l'actualité pour profiter
des fêtes des fêtes de Noël et des fêtes
de fin d'année les macronistes ont
annoncé en catiminiie et toute honte bu
que cette baisse d'impôt n'aurait pas
lieu pire encore au lieu d'une baisse
d'impôt les Français payeront la hausse
des taxes sur l'électricité pour un
montant de 4 à 9 milliards d'euros par
an soit 150 à 300 € par foyer alors que
jamais l'électricité les énergies n'ont
coûté aussi cher comment justifiez-vous
un tel cynisme vous pensiez que personne
ne verrait vos manigances et bien les
députés du rassemblement national
énonceront cette escroquerie fiscale
vous prétendez puiser dans les poches
des Français au nom des finances
publiques mais vous ne faites aucune
économie structurelle vous ne luttez
contre aucun gaspillage et ne toucher à
aucun privilège non contant d'avoir payé
des dizaines de milliards d'euros les
classes moyennes vous allez leur faire
payer les avantages des des oligarques
de la mondialisation car votre
gouvernement va honorer une seule
promesse fiscale celle de créer un
odieux paradis fiscal pour les
richissismes organisations comme la FIFA
ma question est donc 5 monsieur le
ministre quand çaerez-vous donc de
prendre l'argent des Français pour
financer votre débacle budgétaire et
gaspiller les derniers les denniers
publics
plus
privilégci la parole est à Monsieur
Thomas k ministre en charge des comptes
publque merci Madame la la présidente
monsieur le député gonzalz nous ne vous
avons pas attendu pour baisser les
impôts et se préoccuper du pouvoir
d'achat des Français on a nous sommes la
majorité monsieur le député qui avons
baisser de 50 milliards d'euros les
impôts depuis 2017 25 milliards uros
pour les Français baisse de la taxe
d'habitation baisse de la redevance
audioisuelle et dans le projet de budget
et dans le budget que nous avons adopté
indexation du barê indexation du barê de
l'impôt sur le revenu pour 6 milliards
d'euros indexation des prestations
sociales et des pensions de retraite
pour 16 milliards d'euros alors après
vous nous faites des procès sur la
débacle budgétaire et oui en
responsabilité en responsabilité et je
n'ai encore jamais entendu la seule
proposition d'économie venant de vos
bancs oui nous redressons les finances
publiques monsieur le député gonzalz et
est-ce que vous pensez quand on a
protégé protégé les industries les
entreprises 85 milliards d'euros pour le
bouclier énergétique voilà des mesures
concrètes qui ont évité l'effondrement
de nos entreprises des ménages et avec
la baisse des prix de l'énergie il est
temps de revenir en arrière pourquoi
parce qu'il faut réduire not déficit
public en responsabilité pour garantir
notre souveraineté mais j'ai
l'impression que ces objectifs là vous
ne les partagez pas merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la prochaine question va être
posée par Monsieur Hubert
buullefran avant de lui donner la parole
je voudrais qu'on lui rende
collectivement
hommage puisqu'il va poser
aujourd'hui sa dernière question au
gouvernement
député de la 3e circonscription de scène
maritime depuis
2017 opposant au pignâre mais toujours
courtois vous avez également mon cher
collègue exercé plusieurs mandats locaux
notamment comme maire et conseiller
départemental vous vous êtes ainsi
investi avec beaucoup de passion
beaucoup de talent beaucoup d'engagement
au service des Français et la
représentation nationale vous en est
particulièrement
reconnaissante madame la Présidente Mame
Mames et messieurs les ministres madame
la Première ministre mon ultime question
je la dois à un copain
d'enfance rencontré dans les manif sur
les
retraites en ce début d'année il
attendit des résultats
d'examen le diagnostic est tombé maladie
de
Charco en cette fin d'année il est déjà
affecté physiquement il s'avère que
cette terrible
maladie fait l'objet d'une actualité
particulière en lien avec l'action de
l'association pour la recherche sur la
sclérose latérale
amiotrophique en effet plusieurs
ministres sur ces bancs ont apporté ces
dernières semaines des éléments de
réponse attendus par l'association mise
en œuvre d'un travail d'identification
des besoins pour une meilleure prise en
charge des malades COORDIN de santé
spécifique entre la médecine de ville et
l'hôpital nouveaux médicaments autorisé
en accès compassionnel dans notre pays
l'enjeu crucial reste néanmoins la
recherche pour espérer enfin sortir
cette maladie des maladies
incurables ma question est donc simple
peuton
espérer mal Charco soit déclaré grande
cause nationale et que le plan malad
rare dispose d'un engagement financier
sans précédent merci de votre réponse
merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la
parole la parole est à Madame le
Ministre santé et de la prévention merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
Hubert villefran tout d'abord vous dire
toute l'émotion qui est la mienne de
répondre à votre dernière question au
gouvernement nous avons passé pas mal de
temps ensemble sur ces bancs mais aussi
au département de scène maritime et nous
avons eu l'occasion aussi de traverser
ensemble un moment dramatique qui est
celui de l'attentat de Saint-Étienne de
rouvret lorsque vous étiez maire de
cette
commune monsieur le député vous le savez
vous l'avez dit la France entend jouer
un rôle pionnier dans la prise en charge
des patients atteints de maladies rares
à l'occasion des plans nationaux
maladies rares et notamment celui du 4e
qui est en construction à la fois pour
soutenir la recherche et comme vous
l'avez dit à l'accès aux thérapeutiques
améliorer la prise en charge des
personnes qui souffrent de la SLA et
mieux accompagner leurs proches et dents
cela fait partie de notre ambition pour
ce 4e plan qui est en construction et en
cours d'élaboration à la fois nous
devons tenir compte des retours
d'expérience des précédents plans
maladies rares des réflexions sont en
menées sur l'impasse et sur l'errance
diagnostique afin de proposer des pistes
d'amélioration pour favoriser la
recherche et les traitements innovants
le plan national a en outre pour
ambision de favoriser les dialogues
entre les différentes parties prenantes
de l'écosystème maladie rare mais aussi
les industriels en matière de recherche
nous sommes déterminés à avancer le plan
France médecine génomique 2025 doit
permettre des avancé dans la
connaissance de laasa et ouvrir la voie
de meilleure prise en charge de cette
pathologie et de sa recherche en
développant une médecine de précision
avec des thérapies ciblées dans la LFSS
pour 2024 des ajustements sont apportés
au dispositif d'accès précoce et d'accès
compassionnel afin de faire encore
progresser l'accès des patients au
traitement innovant tout en assurant
leur sécurité et leur satnellité
financière l'enjeu c'est aussi et vous
l'avez souligné de mieux accompagner les
patients atteint de SLA au fur et à
mesure de l'évolution de leur maladie
tout en la rassurant la meilleure
qualité de de vie possible je pense
notamment à l'amélioration des parcours
du patient entre la ville et l'hôpital
sur ce sujet monsieur le député le
Gouvernement partage pleinement votre
engagement le pnmr4 se verra dotter de
grands moyens vous pouvez compter sur
notre détermination je sais aussi
compter sur l'engagement des
parlementaires et notamment Monsieur
Philippe Berta je vous souhaite bon vent
et nous savons vous et moi qu'il souffre
très fort en scène maritime et un joyeux
anniversaire à votre voisin monsieur
Jumel merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur vulfan c'est bon
allez-y chers collèges je vous laisse le
soin de faire progresser ce dossier
important pour nos concitoyens merci à
vous
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Inaki
etanis pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre ce 19
décembre 2023 restera comme une date
sombre dans l'histoire de la République
un projet de loi sur l'immigration
inspiré du programme historique de
l'extrême droite et de Jean-Marie Le Pen
a été adopté par le Parlement grâce aux
voix du rassemblement national car
malgré vos éléments de langage les
chiffres sont têttu c'est bien les 88
votes pour du rassemblement national qui
vous permettent d'obtenir une majorité
sur ce texte de la honte la minorité
présidentielle avait fixé des lignes
rouges elles ont toutes été allègrement
transgressées et ce sont désormais les
lignes bleu marines qui sont franchies
vous avez tous cdé
les amendements les articles et surtout
votre honneur cette loi d'armanin le
penioti est une infamme loi de police
des étrangers elle demeurera comme le
moment où le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
s'est votré dans le déshonneur en 2017
et en 2022 nous avons uni nos voix
contre le rassemblement national pour
faire élire Emmanuel Macron ce temps est
désormais révolu puisque le gouvernement
en est désormais le porte-voix le
président du barrage républicain est
devenu celui du naufrage républicain ce
texte a fracturé votre camp mais aussi
le contrat social qui fonde notre
République aujourd'hui j'ai honte pour
vous vous collègues qui comme moi sont
issus de l'immigration et qui ont mêlé
leur voix à l'extrême droite vous avez
permis l'adoption de ce texte si ce
texte était en vigueur à l'arrivée de
vos parents ou de vos grands-parents
vous ne seriez pas ici en ce triste jour
plat je pense aussi et surtout à nos
concitoyens enfants d'étranger qui ont
bénéficié d'êes social qui leur ont
permis d'étudier sereinement à l'école
de la République à ceux qui ont peut
bénéficier automatiquement de la
nationalité française grâce au droit du
sol qui fait l'honneur de pays pour tous
ces gens-là nous dénoncerons ce texte au
Conseil constitutionnel et nous
lutterons contre vos idées mercioup je
merci la parole est à Monsieur é Dupont
Moretti garde des et ministre de la
[Applaudissements]
Justice merci allez s'il vous
plaît merci madame la Présidente il
régnait jusqu'à ce il régnait jusqu'à ce
moment une ambiance assez tranquille et
je voudrais et je voudrais pouvoir et je
voudrais pouvoir vous répondre d'abord
la déchéance de de nationalité monsieur
le député elle est dans le Code civil
c'est Monsieur François Hollande sopéror
de ma part
deuxièmement voyez-vous vous êtes tombé
dans le piège du rassemblement national
qui crie victoire mais
voyez-vous une victoire en réalité c'est
lorsqu'on a livré un combat alors je
vais vous rappeler deux ou trois choses
très simples très très simple d'abord
dans ce texte le RN n'a pas ajouté une
virgule et pas un mot au Sénat il vote
contre le texte
devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée
nationale contre le texte en CMP il ne
propose rien à l'Assemblée nationale
dans l'hémicycle c'est avec vous qu'il
vote monsieur le débuté et avec personne
d'autre qu'est-ce que ça donne au final
ça donne que madame la Présidente Le
Pen vote enfin le texte alors que son
prier ministre aoclamé dit qu'il ne le
votera pas première crise dans votre
gouvernement c'est un compte de Noël qui
nous est raconté à vaincre sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire ça n'est pas une
victoire c'est la plus grande
escroquerie politique de
l'année je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à
[Musique]
Monsieur
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier dusopte
ministre du Travail monsieur le le
ministre notre premier combat c'est
l'emploi l'an passé nous avons
collectivement fait le pari du plein
emploi pour 2027 cet objectif est
d'ailleurs inscrit dans votre périmètre
ministériel cet objectif du plein emploi
est partagé par de nombreux acteurs
économique notamment par éce Monsieur le
Député attendez quelques secondes que
l'émicycle fasse silence on nentend rien
donc vous n'avez pas la parole monsieur
carlolive doit pouvoir poser sa question
allez-y et arrêtez de vous invectiver
les uns les autres monsieur le député
allez-y monsieur le ministre notre
premier combat c'est l'emploi l'an passé
nous avons collectivement fait le pari
du plein emploi pour 2027 cet objectif
est d'ailleurs inscrit dans votre
périmètre ministérielle cet objectif du
plein emploi est partagé par de nombreux
acteurs économiques notamment par la
filière automobile ce fleuron
deindustrie française qui je le rappelle
emploie 350000 personnes hors
intérimaire en France répartie dans 3500
sites est aujourd'hui en plein
bouleversement lié entre autes à
l'électrification du parc automobile à
la transition écologique pour y répondre
elle a fait le choix d'investir dans nos
territoires elle fait le choix de créer
de l'emploi ici en France et en Europe
je pense bien évidemment au gigafactory
dans la vallée des batterie du Nord de
la France mais ce choix est aujourd'hui
confronté au défis de la main d'œuvre du
recrutement et de la formation la
filière investit alors à nos côtés pour
développer les cursistes professionnels
elle investit aussi dans les campus
innovants comme le green campus de
stellantis à poissie qui ouvrira ses
porortte en 2024 et que nous avons
visité ensemble la semaine dernière
monsieur le ministre ce green campus
porte de véritables solutions pour
rendre attractifs les emploi de la
filière automobile en développement pour
ses futurs 8500 salariés 8500 salariés
de nouvelles formes de travail plus
hybride plus adapté à leur demande et au
besoins de l'entreprise monsieur le
ministre à l'Ô des conclusions des
Assises du travail des avancées
proposées sur le terrain comme à poissi
pour transformer les modes de travail et
des objectifs de plein Mo emploi comment
réenchanter l'rait de la filière
industrielle en France quelle réponse
pouvons-nous partager avec nos jeunes
avec nos moins jeunes pour s'orienter
vers l'industrie automobile je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Olivier DOP
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Carl olive
parmi quelques vocifération j'ai entendu
votre question et j'ai plaisir à
rappeler que vous étion ensemble la
semaine dernière à poissie effectivement
pour accompagner la construction d'un
centre de formation le Gren campus du
groupe stellantis justement pour former
au métier de demain c'est un outil
essentiel à la reconquête industrielle
nous conjugons nos forces ministère de
l'Économie ministère du Travail pour
accompagner le retour de l'industrie sur
notre territoire et d'ailleurs au 3è
trimestre de l'année 2023 l'économie
française malgré la légère os du taux de
chômage a augmenté de a augmenté le
nombre d'emplois de 36000 dont 12000
dans le secteur industriel c'est le
dialogue social qui doit faire en sorte
que les métiers soient plus attractifs
et nous y travaillons avec les
partenaires sociaux c'est aussi un
effort de formation que nous devons
faire pour répondre aux tensions de
recrutement connu par ces métiers que
faisons-nous nous déployons à la fois du
FNE formation c'est un fond pour
accompagner la montée en compétences des
salariés actuels et ainsi leur permettre
d'acquérir les compétences nécessaires
aux nouvelles technologies ce sont
275000 millions d'euros que nous pourr y
consacrer l'année prochaine nous avons
un appel à projet porté par le plan
France 2030 qui permet de développer les
formations de demain là aussi ce sont
2,7 milliards d'euros mobilisables nous
faisons en sorte que les demandeurs
d'emploi puissent avoir accès à des
formations qualifiantes pour les métiers
de l'industrie c'est le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
avec la volonté que nous portons avec la
première ministre d'élargir les critères
d'accès à l'éligibilité et au
financement de ces formation aux jeunes
de moins de fin de 6 ans jusqu'à pour
ceux qui sont en demande d'emploi avec
des formations inférieur + 2 mais aussi
en levant toutes les conditions de
formation initiale pour les allocataires
du RSA pour les chômeurs que l'on
qualifie de seniors afin de former un
maximum de monde et de les amener vers
le secteur industriel nous avons une
opportunité majeure qui est de retrouver
notre souveraineté industrielle ça passe
par un autre enjeu qui est de permettre
à l'industrie d'avoir les ressources
humaines d'avoir les compétences
nécessaires pour faire face à tout cela
si nous n'avons pas ces compétences
d'autres les auront ensemble nous avons
pu voir que ces groupes investissent et
nous les accompagnons je vous remercie
monsieur monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sylvie
ferrire pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
collègue ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture en
2013 la France cessait toute
expérimentation d'OGM en pleinchamp elle
faisait alors un choix de raison celui
d'appliquer le principe de précaution et
de ne pas faire pousser n'importe quoi
n'importe où quand on décide de jouer
aux apprentis sorciers et de modifier le
vivant il vaut mie être bien sûr de son
coup car vous le savez comme moi aucune
culture n'est étanche la pollinisation
propage les gênnes des plante de manière
incontrôlable c'est le génie de la
nature qui est à l'œuvre personne ne
peut le remettre dans sa lampe alors la
Commission européenne a eu une idée
brillante elle a cru qu'en changeant les
lettres elle résoudrait le problème
désormais elle ne parle plus d'OGM mais
de NTG ces nouvelles technique génomique
se heurent à des controverses
scientifiques quant à leur impact et
donc au principe de précaution même
enjeu même jeu mais plus aucune règle
les espèces modifiées ne seront ni
tracées ni ne pourront être révoquer on
les retrouvera alors un peu partout dans
toutes les cultures bio ou non dans tous
les écosystèmes et dans toutes les
assiettes sans aucune conscience de leur
impact possible et surtout surtout c'est
la marchandisation et la du vivant par
les multinationales
semencières nos consommateurs méritent
mieux nos agriculteurs méritent mieux
notre environnement mérite mieux
monsieur le ministre la Commission
européenne ne peut agir sans l'aval du
gouvernement alors je vous le demande
pour notre agriculture et pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens allez-vous
laisser l'Union européenne ouvrir cette
boîte de
Pandore je vous remercie la parole est à
Marc fen ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée merci de cette question qui
permet d'éclairer les choses d'abord on
ne gagne jamais à caricaturer les choses
vous essayez d'amalgamer les OGM avec
les NBT et les NGT ça n'est pas la même
chose pardon de vous le dire un UGM
c'est scientifiquement et je reprends la
phrase de la transgénèse c'est-à-dire
incorporer des gèes étrangers d'autres
espèces dans les plantes les nouvelles
techniques génomiques les nouvelles
techniques génomiques c'est le plus
souvent de l'intragénèse pardon de faire
un peu de science ou de la cgénèse ça
permet d'obtenir des mutations ciblé du
génô sur les mêmes plantes et c'est donc
une accélération d'un processus qui se
passerait dans la nature donc on gagne
des années qui sont précieuses deuxème
élément le gouvernement soutient la
proposition de la Commission pourquoi
parce qu'on a besoin d'alternative
madame la députée et qu'on peut pas à la
fois dire il faut lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique il faut adapter
nos cultures au dérèglements climatiques
il faut réduire les produits
phytosanitaires et se priver de l'un des
outils ça n'est pas le seul mais de l'un
des outils qui est prometteur pour
accompagner nos agriculteurs la France a
veillé à trois sujets le premier il
était très important pour nous il a été
d'ailleurs acquis grâce à la présidence
espagnole c'est qu'on ne puisse pas
utiliser cette technique pour créer des
variétés qui seraient résistantes aux
herbicides premier élément deuxème
élément à bien distinguer les catégories
3ème élément à de faire en sorte qu'elle
ne soit pas utilisé c'était d'ailleurs
la demande de la filière bio en filière
bio 4ème élément qu'on fasse en sorte
que on respecte la question de la
brabilité nous sommes tout près d'un
accord avec les l'ensemble des pays
européens moi je m'en réjouis parce que
je pense qu'on a besoin de donner aux
agriculteurs des capacités à engager la
transition et à continuer à produire et
ces outils sont parmi ceux qui sont très
prometteurs voilà madame la députée on a
besoin d'avancer sur ces sujets-là comme
sur d'autres en conscience et avec la
science parce que ce que je dis c'est la
science qui le dit aujourd'hui je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame la
députée donc monsieur le ministre je
vois que pour qui vous vous vous roulez
hein ce sont les multinationales
aujourd'hui la France s'est positionnée
pour pour les NTG euh l'Allemagne se
positionne contre aujourd'hui au niveau
de l'Europe et euh et ben vous maintenez
votre opposition je le constate je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'enfance
parce que le déshonneur du gouvernement
ne s'arrête pas à la question migratoire
et que la pose hivernale arrive alors je
souhaitais vous poser la question de la
civise la commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites faites aux enfants a été créée en
2021 après le livre de Camille Kouchner
30000 personnes ont été auditionnées en
2 ans 82 préconisations en sont sorties
vous avez annoncé le maintien de la
civise en NZ Vincent Édouard Durand et
Nathalie Mathieu de sa tête 11 membres
ont démissionné suite à cette annonce le
choix des personnes nommées à leur suite
interroge Caroline ressalmont a évoqué
ou trop dès sa première prise de parole
sans que cela n'ait suscité aucune
espèce de réaction de votre part ou trop
ou la parole des enfants ridicule is et
la chute qui en a suivi des
condamnations la lecture féministe des
crimes sexuels vous aurait aussi dérangé
85 % des victimes sont des filles 97 %
des agresseurs sont des hommes oui il y
a un rapport genré aux violences
sexuelles trois enfants par classe le
mot inceste est un des mots clés les
plus recherchés sur les sites
pornographiques la pédocriminalité est
banale statistiquement dans cet
hémicycle il y a 57 personnes qui ont
été Vic de pédocriminalité ou d'inceste
et on ne sait pas combien il y a de
pédocriminels parce que nous n'avons pas
de statistiques les 82 préconisations
doivent urgemment être appliqué alors
madame la ministre ma question est
simple est-ce parce que le juge dur ran
Poé l'ampleur des violences faites aux
enfants et la faiblesse de vos
politiques publiques en face que vous
l'avez
évincé je vous remerci la parole est à
Madame Charlotte cobel ministre en
charge de l'enfance merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés madame Sandrine Rousseau d'abord
permettez-moi de m'étonner du soupçon et
du mépris que j'entends dans votre
question à l'endroit du nouveau
président de la civise dont le parcours
l'engagement et l'expertise sont
unanimement reconnu sinon apprécié
permettez-moi aussi de d'en profiter
pour condamner les propos nos et à bons
que je vois circulé depuis quelques
jours au sujet d'un homme et d'une femme
Sébastien Boel et Caroline ressalmon qui
ont accepté cette mission au nom de la
cause qui nous anime tous celle des
enfants et de la protection des enfants
et qui sont engagés dans cette mission
depuis de nombreuses années peut-être
avant moi peut-être avant vous
permettez-moi aussi de penser que la
reconnaissance de la parole des victimes
que l'engagement auprès des victimes n'a
pas de monopole cette parole elle ne se
réduit pas au plébiscit apparent d'un
homme au travail d'une ministre ou même
d'un gouvernement c'est un combat que je
l'ai dit qui doit être mené par tout le
monde et qui a été mené largement et qui
continue à être mené par cette majorité
et par ce gouvernement aucun
gouvernement avant nous n'avait utilisé
le mot inceste sur les 82 préconisations
de la civice qui a été souhaité par le
Président de la République 41 ont déjà
été initié 25 autres sont en cours
d'expertise par une mission
interinpection mise en place par le
gouvernement nous avons souhaité
prolonger la plateforme d'écoute j'ai
dit que je rendrai compte des
préconisations de la civice devant la
représentation parlementaire et devant
la délégation aux droits des enfants
personne n'a fait autant demain avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous saluerons
le travail du nouvel office des mineurs
qui a permis l'un filet un coup de filet
de 80 personnes interpellées il y a
quelques semaines sur les pédocriminels
nous ne lâchons rien nous avons mis des
moyens supplémentaires donc
pardonnez-moi mais je suis engagé on
peut continuer à polémiquer moi je
souhaite tous mes vots de succès au
nouveau président et à nouvelle
vice-présidente je n'ai démissionné
personne le mandat s'arrête le 31
décembre 11 personnes ont démissionné 9
hutes avaient déjà claqué la porte cont
tenu du fonctionnement de la civise neu
personnes avaient déjà claqué la porte
le monopole de personne n Le monopo de
cet engagementame la ministre merci
beaucoup la séance madame Rousseau
allez-y madame les condamnations pour
pédocriminalité ont diminué alors que
les plaintes ont augmenté il faut une
réforme il faut des moyens il faut
l'imprescriptibilité à la fin il faut
une volonté politique je vous remercie
madame la députée la séance des
questions gouvernement est terminée la
séance est
suspendue